les mots lancés un défi très s'appelle
ice baquette challenge wa lâ lui vous
vous souvenez de ça et je parle pas de
moi absolument pas de moi mais vous
souvenez de cette vague de l'an dernier
ce live market challenge pour recueillir
des fonds pour mieux comprendre la sl à
la maladie de lou gehrig maladie
dégénérative
on vous en a beaucoup parlé à l'émission
de cette maladie là parce que je vous le
rappelle 10 secondes notre collègue
bruno bon amigo il en est mort en 2000
13 octobre 2013 il avait été
diagnostiqué une année avant dans son
camp ça a été extrêmement rapide on vous
avait présenté un reportage pour mieux
comprendre cette maladie avec moi alain
bérard jette atteindre l'un cela bonsoir
libera d'ailleurs vous m'aviez lancé le
défi l'an dernier c'est pour ça que je
ne l'avais fait bien sûr pour bruno et
claudine caux qu'on a appris à connaître
au cours de ces années d'ailleurs vous
êtes directrice générale la société de
la sla du québec
on revient sur tout ça parce qu'on a
appris il ya quelques jours qui a eu
quand même une percée importante dans la
recherche médicale
on fait beaucoup de recherches un peu
partout sur la planète et c'est grâce à
l'argent que toutes ces personnes là ont
recueilli en faisant ce qu'on fait pas
jusque là
le circle ans mettant drôle les gens
donnent l'argent c'est grâce à cet
argent là que la recherche a pu évoluer
c'est un fait ça absolument il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de recherche qui se
fait présentement il ya beaucoup de
projets qui vont aller de l'avant en
fait je parlais du chercheur
dernièrement
puis les chercheurs avant il se trouvait
et avait du temps à mettre pour te
lancer de trouver de l'argent des
subventions
on sait que les coupures partout avec
l'événement johannesburg est ça permet
d'avoir de l'argent pour les chercheurs
est de faire ce que lui a dit enfin
vraiment de la recherche et on voit
alors que des mecs se présente
puis chopin abordons dans les prochains
mois claudine caux qu'on va avoir des
chiffres parce que c'est impressionnant
ce qui est arrivé bon vous avez
bénéficié d'un effet de mode
bien des gens d'ailleurs qui ont dénoncé
sommet tant mieux pour vous parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens au regard de
rassembler les chiffres
si on peut les voir bon pour le québec
ne peut rien vous avez ramassé 2,66
millions 10,7 millions canada 115
millions aux états unis
ce site est du jamais vu donnez-nous une
comparaison pour une part à part une
année habituelle inhabituel pour nous
pour la société c'est un point à 1
million d'alors alors on a triplé des
fonds qu on a recueilli 70% talent et
pour la recherche puis 7 millions
étaient jumelés par la fondation numéro
qui devenu 20 millions pour la recherche
alors vraiment qu'est ce qu'elle vient
ici vraiment un impact des fonds
disponibles pour la recherche et pour
les services est qu on offre à tous les
québécois pour les soutenir tout au long
de la maladie
oui parce qu'on sait que pour les
projets maladie c'est extrêmement
difficile
alain bérard vous y êtes atteint comment
ça va ça va quand même bien j'ai la
formule 1
si l'on peut dire par rapport à d'autres
personnes ne savons plus rapidement tant
mieux je suis encore là je peux à
profiter de la vie avec ma famille les
enfants mais aussi les porte paroles et
aider à faire une sieste à la cantine
jette moins mobile que parce que les
gens vous regardent puis vois absolument
aucun handicap mais vous êtes arrivé ici
il faudrait en chaise roulante c'était
un grand sportif jacquemod et mobiles
qu'avant
absolument et j'imagine difficulté à
avaler ça faire et pas comme ça mais je
ne dis pas qu'il est là expliquez-moi
chacun d'entre vous la paire c'est là ce
que c'est important au niveau de la
recherche qu'on a découvert une protéine
justement qui pourrait ralentir
je laissais aller parce que les plus
impliqués dans la recherche c'est
certain que l'événement de souris
nourries représente un capital en trois
ans une protéine qui t a même connu
mélanie avec ceux qui savaient des jeux
ils peuvent aller encore plus rapidement
et on parle peut-être de faire une forme
de
modifier génétiquement cette protéine
l'offre pouvoir éventuellement
l'appliquer aux personnes c'est chouette
ce propos demain matin à hong kong au
stage danse
rouleau peint alors ils rapportent
traitement de les mater non mais c'est
ça l'objectif c'est de trouver un
traitement parce que cette maladie
fatale et aucun traitement en ce moment
alors les chercheurs veulent trouver
quelque chose pour au moins la ralentir
puis jusque temps qui ralentit les
familles ont besoin de soutien comme ce
nous ça nous amène de l'espoir 7
parce que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on entend parler de deux nouvelles de
la sorte
mais ce que nous ça nous dit comme
personne atteint comme personne
impliquée
les bénévoles et tous ceux qui sont
touchés de plomb de loin comme toi
patrice au niveau 2 de lie c'est là ce
que ça nous donne c'est de l'espoir pour
le futur mais il faut pas que les gens
nous oublie alors justement pas à l abri
il ya une grosse mois de l'an dernier
les gens disaient les banderoles le
faire on passe à autre chose c'est cette
c'est ça votre crème en fait que nous on
dit c'est qu'à chaque mois d'août
jusqu'au bout sonatrach est ce qu'on se
dit ainsi que l'année passée c'était là
cette année on est encore dans les
genres sont mobilisés beaucoup plus au
sud les personnes atteintes des familles
plaintes de personnes de 20 ans qui avec
leurs familles organise des icebergs et
nous on en a fait un on était quinze
personnes atteintes
chez une amie qui est atteint que nous
avait invités pour un barbecue on était
quinze nous aidants et aidantes
en effet la halle sportive alors les
gens qui sont atteints les salons les
gens qui sont impliqués dans les salons
sont mobilisés ils nous défient en fait
c'est de continuer la vague et qu'est ce
que ça te fait qu as tu entendu tout
peut être lu des critiques dans les
journaux les gens des morts les vedettes
font ça pour se faire voir que ces
trajets devenu on les gens savent même
pas pourquoi ils font ça c'est quoi ta
réaction
moi je te dirai que cette année les gens
qui le moment ils connaissent beaucoup
plus la raison pourquoi les faits
l'année passée peut-être qu'il savait
pas mais nous ce qui est important c'est
justement de faire connaître l'analyse
alors c'est les gens aujourd'hui le fond
cette année parce qu'ils le savent
pourquoi ils le font et ils font les
dons en conséquence nous on est très
heureux de se creuser tout combien sa
touche de personnes cette maladie au
québec et 100 personnes qui sont
atteintes mais comme une maladie fatale
pour chaque thématique
il ya quelqu'un qui perd sa vie à chaque
année alors on est chez feulement pas
mais le nombre de personnes qui sont
touchées par cette maladie c'est c'est
énorme et puis chaque fois qu'on parle à
quelqu'un je n'étais qu'un connaît
quelqu'un qui touché par cette maladie
alors il faut pas qu'on lâche et comme
m'avait dit il faut faire connaître là
cela puis je pense si les gens ont une
meilleure connaissance de la maladie
cette année comparé landes de l'année
passée je suis très content je sois est
venu sur d'autres plates ou ça nous ça
permet de dire aux jaaxay c'est loin
d'être un jeu
cette histoire n'a bien sûr on le fait
façon amusant mais derrière ça il ya une
recherche fondamentale qui en a d'autres
conspuent bien sûr et celle là est
importante aussi alain béral bonne
chance govou vois aller on est très fort
il ya des gens qui l'ont pas faire cette
année qu'il offrait des pentes ils
peuvent sont à remettre le vidéo on
assite à vite possible sur les salles au
québec on voit l'adresse à sa langue
tirée québec prend 1,6 à claudine caux
calais bérard merci beaucoup c'est 4